Er ist der größte planet des sonnensystems und hat 300 mal so viel masse wie die erde doch wie der jupiter
entstanden sein könnte davon hatte die wissenschaft bisher kaum eine ahnung oder
wusste vieles entscheidendes nicht ein forschungsteam aus zürich hat dazu jetzt ein neues modell entwickelt mit super spannenden erkenntnissen klicks um science-fiction
herzlich willkommen
Angefangen hatte alles mit daten von meteoriten die im vergangenen jahr auf einer amerikanischen
konferenz vorgestellt worden waren die analyse der
isotope ließ damals nämlich darauf schließen dass unser sonnensystem in seiner uhrzeit in zwei
regionen aus staub und gas aufgeteilt war das etwa zwei millionen jahre lang
wissenschaftlerinnen und wissenschaftler weltweit schlossen aus dieser beobachtung dass der gasriese jupiter
damals ein als eine art teilende barriere für das sonnensystem diente dabei störte er offenbar die staubscheibe
und erzeugte so eine über dichtung konkret konnte sich das material außerhalb seiner umlaufbahn
nicht mit dem material das sich innerhalb seiner umlaufbahn befand vermischen in diesem 2 millionen jahren wuchs der jupiter wohl von
20 auf 50 erdmassen und die trennung und seine barrierefunktion wurde aufgehoben als der junge planet so viel masse
angereichert hatte im gestein um zu lenken so konnte es auch in die inneren regionen des
sonnensystems gelangen zu dieser hypothese passt auch das neue modell des schweizerischen
forschungsteams das nähere infos zu der entstehung des jupiters herausfinden konnte demnach ist der gasriese in verschiedenen phasen
gewachsen der planeten embryo hat also zunächst zentimeter große kieselsteine
angesammelt und so innerhalb von einer million jahren einen kern gebildet die darauf folgenden zwei millionen jahre verliefen etwas
entspannter hier wurde der aktuellen studie zufolge
kilometer große planeten sie male angehäuft also so werden die bausteine und vorläufer vom planeten genannt dieser prozess setze
sehr viel wärme frei denn die risiken objekte trafen den immer größer werdenden planeten mit gigantischer wucht dazu einer der
forscher jan albert von der universität
während der ersten etappe
brachten die kieselsteine die masse in der zweiten phase
fügten die planeten sie male auch etwas masse hinzu aber was noch wichtiger ist sie brachten energie
nach drei millionen jahren hatte der jupiter somit 50 mal so viel masse wie die erde
dann begann die dritte phase seiner entwicklung in der sich gas anreicherte heute verfügt der gasriese über
300 mal so viel masse wie die erde das modell zeigt also dass der jupiter sich phasenweise
deutlich langsamer entwickelt hat als man bislang angenommen hatte dem gängigen modell zufolge nämlich hatte sich zunächst durch die ansammlung
zentimeter großer gesteins körper der planeten kern gebildet als dieser die masse von 20 erdmassen überschritt
sorgte die schwerkraft dafür dass gas aus der umgebung aufgenommen wurde dadurch wiederum wurde bislang ein sich selbst verstärkender
extrem rasantes anwachsen des planeten erklärt noch das modell des schweizerischen
forschungsteams konnte jetzt auch zeigen wodurch genau dieses schnelle anwachsen also was man bisher vermutet
verhindert wurde
demnach hat sich der entstehende planet extrem heiß aufgeheizt und zwar durch die eben erwähnten schweren einschläge
kilometer großer gesteins körper der planeten sie male in dieser phase herrschte eine extreme temperatur die dafür gesorgt hat dass der
jupiter keine leichten gaza haben sich binden konnte dass es auch die erklärung dafür
warum es zwei millionen jahre gedauert hat bis der jupiter von 20 auf 50 erdmassen angewachsen ist das forschungsteam ist jetzt
optimistisch dass diese ergebnisse auch helfen können rätsel rund um die entstehung von exoplaneten sowie von neptun und
uranus zu lösen und jetzt clixoom wird werbefrei keine primär mit eurer hilfe
immer wenn wir entsprechend viele kanal mitglieder gewonnen haben
schalten wir die werbung für jeweils einem video im monat ab bald ist es beim ersten video soweit werdet also mitglied hier unter dem video
draufklicken also hier drunter und bekommt dazu noch exklusive extra videos exklusive live streams wie kommenden dienstag und noch ein paar weitere
privilegien die sehr lustig unter anderem sind ein riesen dank an alle diejenigen die schon dabei sind
absolute hammer es werden immer mehr
wenn ihr immer
garantiert über aktuelle videos informiert werden wollt dann hättet mich übrigens bei whatsapp dann bekommt ihr den link zum video vor allen an
von mir persönlich auf euer handy einfach hier draufklicken und natürlich nicht das abo vergessen und natürlich nicht zu vergessen auf die
genau glocke zu klicken ja und hier geht es weiter mit also hier neue jupiter fakten der raumsonde juno bis dann
bleibt dran